hello everybody and welcome to part 11
of let's play penumbra overture all
right I just got gasoline and a key
Peter what I don't know oh I just had a
brainstorm in between the last episode
in this the wooden plank I realized that
I got a saw a while ago a fact that you
all probably realized a long time ago
but didn't mention it to me I mean
whatever not helping me oh I bet this
works first try saw boom done
I can't believe that worked when five
explosive canisters did not that's
that's amazing
Oh more guard dogs bringing on weight
too tough for them anyway
Oh victory flash what are we at oh do a
puppy here's my box can't beat me in my
box I'll bring it on Brianna first right
boom right now face blood every which
way
oh yeah coming ah don't run come back
for another taste of justice oh yeah you
want some more
I got morning come on come on
Oh who's a little baby bring it bring it
on oh oh ah ha ha yep yep that must have
hurt take another one oh don't want to
take another one too bad cuz I got tons
in storage getting out for free come
back I want another piece ah but you
don't
I didn't think so Oh aah oh hey oh not a
problem [ __ ] oh [ __ ] aah
come on swing the controls are very
unintuitive spam right now but oh you
want a piece
buh-bam come on bring it
ha ha ha nice job dog wow you're really
getting that canister man what do you
think I'm in there is that really what
you thought oh
post-up oh let's don't take your
medicine come on BAM [ __ ] yes right
don't even try to get up oh no miss oh
I'm ready for you I'm ready boom
oh you to [ __ ] up boom oh you're dead on
you're dead too yeah winner winner
chicken dinner
where's my chicken dinner the door
doesn't even open oh wow doggie
I'm never hiding in one of those huh a
dog can just headbutt a steel door off
its hinges I don't think I should hide
in there all right
auxiliary shaft ooh nope ah ba ba ba I
know that's a lot oh that's far in the
future never mind the name of excavation
TB I will be over hey elevated cast
seismic technique and our discoveries
great importance to the organization
best of luck everyone
ah ha ha ha
faced who's having hi ah chief attorney
cometh all right
all I remember is substance 63 that's
the only thing I'm remembering
that's all I care about time to go the
auxilary shaft hey hey hey hey hey all
right shut up oh this looks cool oh
there's a machine oh yeah I got gas and
a key I'm so great Oh
actually prepared oh yeah that's good
I'll shove gas right in the front oh
really really oh that is so pathetic all
that is pathetic
all that is pathetic Oh a bit all right
yeah I like this game Pook ooh one of
these I'll know whispers
uh-huh okay screaming begins okay father
what have you done yeah this John's
father what a douche uh-huh yeah it's
getting crowded in here whatever all
right
uh yeah jump up high on the top shelf
always done gotcha [ __ ] a power cabinet
great job John you must be a proud about
that one all right where's this other
end go aw does it go in right in here
yeah go go I shut up don't talk to me
like that John I will f you up whole
thing looks clean then why doesn't that
work rusted shut that is so pathetic
that I can't even get it to go yes oh
shut up you broom can i broom it boom
broom I'm gonna kill the next dog with a
broom cuz this looks like an awesome
weapon alright I got nothing in my
inventory that could possibly do this so
obviously the solution is not here
moving on moving forward yep alright
more doggies bring it on pickaxe
anything in here anything in these
really bad hiding places nope nope oh
how about you oh yeah oh yeah finally
something useful maybe I didn't check in
here good night nope that was nothing
whatever oh right I need a map cuz I
don't know where I'm going
uh-huh
what's up here anything nothing nothing
a hiding place for the cowards that do
hide I just go on top of boxes it's not
technically hiding when the dogs still
know where I am right right okay
and up there I went over there I went up
there to the auxiliary shaft when in
that little kevie corner you go back
this way yeah oh yeah so smart oh so
smart
ah yeah so strong too nothing in here oh
no oh no no no not again
oh boy okay all right let me think
notes tell me what to do my name she
needs ignition key I have an addiction
at ignition key all right huh ah what
else was there what else was there okay
the storage room was locked I got in
back way this door needed to be sawed in
half there was one more door that needed
to be opened what was it why was it who
was it where was I don't think I need to
ask any more questions
Oh victory flash what did I Vic to rise
huh something change something change
that I can find yeah yeah okay went to
the tool shed where's that map can I be
map map map no there's
I'm just gonna work this out all that
place down there doesn't need to be gone
excavation went in there too getting the
storage got the gasoline key toolshed
been in there don't need it the only
place let's do the auxilary shed shaft
shed shaft okay may I didn't really look
thoroughly in that room maybe there was
something in the room that could help me
out maybe I don't know probably not
probably I'm missing something
oh I said something aren't I never could
blow it up with dynamite I'll try that
why not could happen who knows no dogs
left after I got through with them punch
them all on their face
big ugly faces not like mine big
handsome face all right come on all
right looking around actually giving a
thorough this corner is empty I've
already looked at this corner but I will
look again what's up here uh-huh oh well
what does that matter to me shut up John
I almost called you Daniel I'm not gonna
do that what's under here anything Nick
nope
hole punch it nothing
come on Oh push it with I'll push it
with my with my muscles shut up I don't
care oh oh so strong oh yeah
alright maybe I can get on top of it no
I don't know I'm trying everything yeah
my way Cohn you know what's good for you
alright getting up here on - alright I'm
on top of it that do anything nothing a
whole lot of nothing
burn it off shut up John don't judge me
come on dynamite this [ __ ] take this
fuel tank [ __ ]
yar boom alright let's try that boom ah
you shut your face
better if something you don't care I
don't even care anymore John's just an
idiot he's always gonna be an idiot okay
I got a pause it here I'm gonna figure
this out so that you don't wait around
and watch me like flail and scream and
curse so thank you all for watching I'll
see you in part 12 of let's play with
let's play penumbra overture
ba-bye